شهد اصحاب الملياردو غير عاديه لثرواتهم
خلال سنوات الجائحه والازمات الاقتصاديه
العالميه منذ 20 20 استحوض اغنى واحد
بالمئه من البشر على 26 تريليون دولار اي
63% من جميع الثروات الجديده بينما ذهب 16
للبيع دولار وهي 37% فقط الى باقي سكان
العالم كل ملياردير حصل على ما يقرب 1.7
مليون دولار مقابل كل دولار من الثروه
العالميه الجديده التي يكسبها من البشر
الفقراء يظهر التقرير ان 95 شركه غذاء
بطاقات ارتفعت ارباحها باكثر من الضعف في
عام 2022 ودفعت منها
257 مليار دولار الى المساهمين الاغنيه
مثلا اسره سام مولتون التي تملك نصف شركه
8.5 مليار دولار خلال العام الماضي وشاهد
الملياردير الهندي جوتام اذاني صاحب شركه
طاقه كبرى ارتفاعا بثروته بنسبه 46%
بمقدار 42 مليار دولار في عام 2022 وحده